sugar stay
Mr Speaker the Armed Forces capabilities
allowed a fence to meet a range of
domestic and Global commitments to
fences reorganizing and re-equipping to
face future threats however as I have
previously stated as the threats change
we need to change with it any specific
changes related to personal numbers or
military equipment capabilities will be
determined once the updated to the
Defense command paper has concluded
which I expect to happen in June
thank you Mr Speaker while conscious
that my right honorable friend has
accepted the conclusions of last year's
1922 defense committee report
um and also and when drafting his
command paper and also I'm conscious of
the fact that there is real concern
about
um the um we're about to hear about the
integrated review and indeed one-off
increases what does he think it will
take for this house to sustainably
increase defense spending giving
geopolitical events
I'm grateful to my right I'm a friend uh
look first and foremost I think we've
been sustainably increasing our defense
since 2020. the Prime Minister
recognizes the dangerous World we're in
and that was recognized on that Autumn
statement uh where both the chancellor
and the Prime Minister recognize the
importance of increasing defense
spending the Prime Minister has
obviously uh talked over the weekend
about defense spending there will be a
budget later in the week and I then I
think there'll be some further
discussions to have
thank you madam Deputy speaker of course
the former head of the British army lord
dannett said last month that and I quote
the planned Cuts in the strength of the
army must be stopped and fresh
investment must pour into our artillery
air defense Communications and Logistics
capability what is the Secretary of
State who have has overseen some of
these Cuts now going to do to reverse
and to build back the capacity that Lord
Dana and others are calling for
well I think if the honorable member had
been listening he'd know that in our
Defense command paper we were investing
into uh air defense electronic warfare
signals intelligence Communications all
the things he's just reeled off but
maybe he doesn't bother to risen the
original thing secondly uh you know I'm
Madam Deputy speaker I think it's
interesting the labor party heckling we
haven't heard a single penny a single
penny of their defense plans in the last
few years even the rusty speed by the
French bench themselves couldn't put a
finger on the money first and foremost
uh we are investing in our defense we've
had a record increase since 2020 it
Compares from the labor party's record
that in 1997 they inherited 2.7 of GDP
continued to to fall all the way and
only at the very last minute when they
had a 36 billion ban black hole did they
try and rectify it
chair of the select committee to buy a
Sellwood thank you madam Deputy speaker
conscious that there's a statement to
follow could I just pause and say thank
you to the defense secretary and his
team for the tireless work they've done
in trying to secure additional funding
11 billion worth and an increase in
defense spending of 2.5 percent it
wasn't to be our military will be
affected by that not least our land
forces but I do welcome the orcas
agreement which will secure hundreds of
Highly skilled jobs up and down the
country
could I ask of the three billion
additional funding for the nuclear
Enterprise is part of that any part of
that part of the 10 billion reserve for
Dreadnought or is it ring fence for the
orcus procurement program and of the 5
billion that's coming through is any of
it subject to vat which of course means
one-fifth of it will go back to the
treasury
my right armor kind of makes an
interesting point about the details of
the announcement obviously the details
will come forward in the budget what I
can say is that the two billion pounds
plus of money is new money and is not is
not part of uh The Reserve or anything
else and is separate to the 2.3 billion
pounds for Ukraine it also comes on top
of the 560 million pounds of extra money
for uh weapons and uh restocking that
was announced in the Autumn statement on
the nuclear a chapter the three billion
pounds is a recognition of the need for
increased defense capability in that
space but also the need to now invest in
infrastructure that if we didn't start
now it wouldn't be fit for purpose when
August starts towards the end of the
decade
Richard Ford thank you madam Deputy
speaker we understand from the press and
as The Honorable member for Bournemouth
has said we anticipating an additional 5
billion pounds for defense between now
and 2025. uh the mod has said that the
secretary of state is delighted with the
settlement and uh this represents a
commitment of an upward trajectory given
the impact of Defense inflation and the
full-scale invasion of Ukraine what does
he make of plans to reduce the size of
the army to 72 and a half thousand by
2025.
well the reduction in the size of the
army was also coupled with a record
investment 24 billion in the armed
forces at the same time it was also
recognition that the most important
thing is to make sure we give the men
and women of our Armed Forces whichever
service they are in the correct
equipment at the correct time and create
a 360 Armed Forces there is simply no
point playing a numbers game if you
don't equip them properly you don't
house them properly you don't care for
them properly and you don't deploy them
properly now you might want to play a
numbers game I don't want to turn our
soldiers into Cannon for her
can I start by saying how the whole
house will be delighted to see you back
in your in your seats
[Applause]
um I very much pay tribute to the
secretary and the entire team for the
battle they've fought the treasury of
the last few weeks but the five billion
is disappointing particularly if three
million goes to the goes to Orcas and
1.9 billion goes to filling up our
warehouses it actually means a cut and
defensive enrolled increases it I was
encouraged nonetheless by what the
secretary said remember to go about the
fact that buddies on Wednesday inverse
all the remarks he made which seemed to
me to indicate that maybe more money to
come am I being over optimistic
foreign
remember all departments uh Marvel
friend would know that all departments
are currently within their current
compounded spending review and the next
comprehensive review is due effectively
in 18 months uh two years time and
therefore while of course all
departments including defense and
transport and health suffer from
inflationary pressures with the higher
inflation of course the right thing to
do is to make sure we live within the
envelope and where possible seek relief
for a range of challenges that's what
I've been seeking in these next two
years with the treasury but also I have
said consistently the most important
thing is the head Mark for the long-term
direction of defense spending so the
defense spending is no longer declining
as it has done for the last 30 three
decades it is on the upward trajectory
since 2020 it has been on that upper
trajectory this grant of the extra money
continues that momentum that's
incredibly important I hope hope to see
the head Mark in detail be announced
soon
shutter Secretary of State John Healy
thank you madam W speaker in November
the defense secretary told the select
committee yes the inflationary pressure
on my budget for the next two years is
about 8 billion pounds
from the media briefing at the weekend
we know he's got a welcome 5 billion
pounds earmarked for stockpiles and the
UK's nuclear program but the Armed
Forces will see this funding as a defeat
for the mod in government there's no new
money for pressures on the core defense
budget
no new money to help deal with
capability gaps or even to deal with
that inflation so
when the National Audit office has
already said the mod cannot afford the
capabilities needed in the 2021
integrated review how is he going to
ensure that precisely the same doesn't
happen again with today's 2023
integrative review
what I'm going to do which his
government failed to do is I'm going to
make sure that the Defense command paper
reflects the budget I have I have always
been consistent that the government's
ambition should match its stomach should
match the money it does if you don't get
that in tandem what you will discover is
black holes grow over the years his
government was part of that and the last
time previous conservative governments I
have come to this house consistently to
take responsibility for what our
governments have done in the past I'll
be interested to see if he will
well of course in 2010 when labor left
government we were spending 2.5 percent
of GDP on defense that's a level that's
been nowhere near matched in any other
13 years since Madam Deputy speaking the
secretary of state is now the
conservatives longer serving defense
secretary but that means he's got a
track record of his own he's cut the
Army to 76 000 with more cuts to come
he's got the Ajax armored vehicle six
years late with still no in-service date
he's gotten delayed new wedge-tailed
Century planes and he's got growing
doubts from allies about Britain meeting
in full its NATO obligations now he
admitted to this house Madam Deputy
speaker last month the forces have been
hollowed out and underfunded with
conservative government so will he
accept
his extra defense funding today can only
mean more of the same
Madam W speaker do you know if people
came to this house with some real
genuine honesty about track records of
their governments they were part of we
might be in a better position for the
armed forces the thing that we should
strive for is that the men and women the
Armed Forces know that their leaders
their political leaders are prepared to
be clear about the past mistakes and
talk about the future with some honesty
Madame Deputy speaker the national order
offers report
made a view of the labor party's
governing of Defense I have it here
because colleagues on that side of the
house often forget the Department's poor
financial management has led to severe
funding shortfall of up to 36 billion
pounds in defense spending over the next
10 years when the department well the
national office is not true Madam Deputy
speaker it's not true they made it out
Madame speaker for example the comment
when the department signed the contract
for the aircraft carriers it was aware
the overall defense budget was
unaffordable Madam nephew speaker they
were they were party to the crime at the
time but they won't come to this house
now and be honest about their role in it
and the things you need to do to fix it
for the future
and and we won't have interventions from
people who are sitting down there are
plenty of opportunities to ask questions
when you're standing up
Richard Drex
about to speak can I say how nice to see
you back in your place very great
pleasure can I commend my right old
friend the defense secretary and his
excellent plant bench team because I
know for a fact they are fighting for
every single penny they can get but as
it's been said and I must agree the 5
billion Powers is not sufficient to
ensure our core armed forces are
properly equipped and prepared for God
forbid something that we all dread as
the world taught us towards World War
III potentially
where do you agree with me now that will
perhaps ask what on Earth is going
through the mind of the treasury
officials
look I think
in defense of my colleagues the treasury
the treasury is trying to balance an
economic situation both covert that
means we have to make sure we cut our
cloth and make sure that we return to an
economic credibility that's so important
for growing our tax receipts and our
income I think one of the roles I can
play is to come to this house and be
honest about the state of our Armed
Forces honest about what caused the 30
years of the challenge that both he and
I experience serving in them and what we
can do to fix it I think that's the
first thing the Defense command paper
will make sure that we are very clear in
where we're going to spend the money to
make sure that the future is secure for
the men and women of the Armed Forces
SNP spokesman Dave Dugan thank you madam
Deputy speaker in terms of military
personnel what is the Secretary of
State's understanding of the recruitment
crisis in defense with the Army in
particular and especially so in the
Royal Regiment of Scotland fourth
Battalion the Highlander satisfies
almost 20 percent of its vacancies from
the Commonwealth is it his assessment
that this is the due to the poor service
accommodation mediocre pay lack of
career opportunities or substandard
equipment that's driving young Scots
away from a career in the British army
an officer in a Scottish regiment Madam
Deputy speaker I remember distinctly not
being allowed to go and recruit in
Townsville schools where SNP counselors
ran those schools I distinctly remember
that the s p were so unwelcoming to
members of the Armed Forces it was
having a detrimental effect to
recruiting uh I'd be very interested in
the SMP has now changed the tune they
certainly have on NATO membership they
used to only remember not want to be
part of NATO they now do but I think the
other thing is you know I I don't see
the Army characterized as The Honorable
member has just described them if you
carry on talking them down like that no
wonder people aren't that Keen to join
there's been a recruitment challenge the
Infantry for as long as I was serving in
the Army at many many years both under
the labor government and the
conservative government what we have to
do is make sure the offer is improved
which is one of the reasons we did
things like wrap around child care to
reflect how people live and it's why
we're investing in both married
accommodation and single accommodation
Dave do good Madame Deputy speaker he
says he doesn't recognize the um
characterization the characterization is
based in fact and sticking back in
reality where Germany allocates 100
billion extra Euro in response to
Ukraine the UK allocates an extra 5
billion the United States is frustrated
that the British army is no longer a top
level fighting force that the RAF takes
10 years to train a pilot in combat air
Army procurement can order a pizza and
get it delivered on time and on budget
and the Navy barely has enough f-35s for
one aircraft carrier much less too isn't
it the case to the great frustration of
men and women in uniform that this Tory
government over the last 13 years has
created an ornamental Defense Force nice
to look at don't ask it to do very much
or sustain it for very long
getting lessons from the SNP on
procurement I mean Ferguson Shipyard
Clinging On by its thing on earth when
when push comes to shove they buy their
ferries from Turkey uh not from Scotland
when they've got a perfectly good Clyde
in which to build them now he goes on
about uh you know all the issues that he
thinks is wrong with the Armed Forces uh
from a from a man who is going to
campaign to break Scotland away from the
United Kingdom reduce the Scottish Armed
Forces to a rubber dinghy and of course
just tell everyone else tell everyone
else that it's all the thought of the
English the reality is Scotland is a
proud contributor to Armed Forces has
been in history and is today and also
the accommodation that the soldiers have
today the experiences they have in the
equipment is a far better equipment and
experiences many of us had in the early
90s
and and what would be really nice if
once in a while the SNP in Scotland
actually did more than stand in front of
ceremonial troops got out there how help
soldiers help soldiers be recruited help
the schools talk about what's important
about defense rather than always talk it
down
Chris armor two man W speaker
with permission Madam Nipsey speaker may
I answer questions 2 and 12 together our
commitment to Nato and your Atlantic
security is unconditional in response to
Russia's illegal war in Ukraine we have
enhanced our horse posture in Estonia
and set warships and fighter aircraft to
Southeast Europe and the Mediterranean
we contribute to every NATO Mission and
declare the UK's nuclear deterrence to
Nato the UK is committed to remaining
NATO's leading European Ally
speaker a recent report by the defense
select committee raised concerns about
the UK's lack of ammunition reserves the
committee States and I quote that the
inability to restock our supplies puts a
great risk our own defense along with
our commitments to supporting Ukraine I
know the minister will reply saying that
there are now actually today there are
two billion pounds worth of stockpiles
but he can't just magic at Munitions off
the shelf these can take years to be
created so what Assurance can you
provide me and the house but this
shortage will not impact our own
domestic capabilities but also our wider
commitments to Nato very well Madam
speaker The Honorable gentleman makes a
a very sensible point and the report by
the select committee uh is being read at
the moment and will be responded to as
would be expected but there is an
important distinction to make Madame
Deputy speaker only a small proportion
of the equipment and stockpiles that we
are providing to the ukrainians are
coming from the current active entry and
stockpiles of the UK military a very
large proportion of the ammunition is at
or slightly beyond what will be its uh
date by which we would normally seek to
dispose of it an even larger proportion
of it the majority in fact is being
sourced or manufactured from stockpiles
or manufacturing capabilities overseas
Samantha Dixon
notwithstanding the Secretary of States
earlier on willingness to play a numbers
game it is a reality the reality that
ministers plan to cut the size of the
army to 73 000 by 2025 at a time when
NATO has agreed to increase its high
Readiness forces to three hundred
thousand will be updated into integrated
review halt cuts to Army numbers
my right humble friend the secretary of
state has been clear all along that if
the facts change so will our approach to
force structure but it's important to
note that for size and Readiness are not
necessarily directly connected a future
a future Force madodective speaker may
require fewer people because of
Automation and artificial intelligence
or it may not now we're studying the
lessons from Ukraine carefully we came
to a judgment in the last IR that was
very clear and as we work towards the
publication of a refresh of
of course we'll be looking at whether
the assumptions of the last command
paper are still sound
Bob Stuart thank you madam Deputy
speaker could I ask my very good friend
whether this additional money for
defense will allow us to provide more
teeth arm units preferably support arm
units enable us to Nato
um the reality is is that we are still
providing a very large number of
Frontline units to Nato particularly in
the maritime and air domains but I know
my honorable and Gallant friend's
principal concern will be around land
forces but even there the UK continues
to provide the most credible of high
Readiness formations to the alliance but
he made an important Point Madam Deputy
speaker because
units as you wish but without the
logistics and the Strategic enablers
that get them to the front line they're
not worth having and the Secretary of
State and I and other colleagues on the
front bench have been clear for years
now that actually what urgently needs
reinvestment is not a regrowth of our
fighting Echelon but a refreshing out of
the logistics and the enablers that for
very good reasons over the last 20 years
haven't been needed but now so
desperately up
Robert courts thank you madam Deputy
speaker on the logistics and uh enabling
points uh the right number of friends
just mentioned when we look at our
obligations to Nato and to Ukraine and
particularly the stockpiling and
ammunition Point has already been raised
our ministers looking at what can be
done on a procurement basis commonly
with NATO allies
absolutely Madame Deputy speaker and as
the house might imagine the UK is not
alone in rediscovering the importance of
stockpiles and strategic enablers over
the last year it's also not alone in
finding out that industrial capacity
cannot be turned on like that and so
working with allies around the alliance
both through the alliance itself and
also bilaterally is clearly a very
attractive option
Shadow Minister Luke Pollard
thank you Mum that's liquor in this
weekend
senior British military officer raised
doubts over whether the UK could still
claim to be a leading NATO member
because of the hollowing out of the
Army's warfighting capabilities
the minister has so far baited the
question but with today's funding
announcement being limited to nuclear
Enterprise and stockpiles can the
minister confirm whether it's still his
Department's policy to cut troop numbers
by 10 to cut the reserves and provide no
additional funding to plug the gaps in
Britain's War fighting warfighting
capabilities
is because the shadow Minister as the
representative of a naval constituency
does our Armed Forces a huge disservice
in focusing on simply the Army when
looking at our contribution to Nato the
UK commits its entire nuclear deterrence
to Nato the only country that does so
the UK commits a number of Maritime task
groups in any given year to Nato more
than almost any other NATO Ally the UK
commits handsomely to air policing and
other air deployments and through the
arc the third UK Division and the
various High Readiness armored
formations the UK contributes
prominently in the land domain as well
probably more number three Madam Deputy
speaker
say what a pleasure it is to see you
back and can I um can I also request
Madam speaker that I answer questions
three and ten together and so doing
declaring my interest as a veteran on
the 2nd of March I jointly commissioned
a review with the minister for Veterans
Affairs into the role and scope of
government welfare provision and
services for veterans this will include
provisioned by the ministry of Defense
under veterans UK the review will focus
on examining the Effectiveness and
efficiency of welfare services for
veterans and how we can do better as
part of a program of continual
Improvement
Robbie Moore he Madam Deputy speaker
Armed Forces breakfast clubs provide
vital support and social opportunities
for veterans and Armed Forces serving
Personnel we have one in Keithley and we
are hoping to get one off the ground in
ilkley will the minister join me in
praising those who are involved in
organizing them and also set out what
additional support the government can
provide these fantastic veteran-led
organizations
really grateful of my own friends
question he is of course absolutely uh
right our armed forces and veterans
breakfast clubs are really excellent
initiative which have taken route across
14 countries with 150 000 members they
provide a sense of belonging and
Community for many who have served our
country and if I may say on a personal
level that I like a good Yorkshire
breakfast and if the opportunity arises
I'd love to visit his Breakfast Club
David Simmons thank you madam Deputy
speaker
my constituent Steve Graham served in
our Armed Forces for over 20 years
traveling the world and finally settling
overseas at the site of his last posting
and despite being a UK taxpayer with a
UK phone when he sought to retrieve he
was required to pay the full overseas
rate to treat it as a foreign student as
part of his re-education was posted to
his life I'd like to ask my old friend
will you meet with me to discuss the
case of Mr Graham and other people who
made following long service in Armed
Forces seek to retreat find themselves
facing significant financial barriers to
do so
I'm grateful to my old friend for that
um I have every sympathy and of course
I'll meet with him at the moment for an
adult to be eligible for funding for
further education they must ordinarily
be resident in England on the first day
of the first Academic Year of the course
and throughout the three years
immediately preceding that date the
matter is primarily won for the
Department for Education as he'll know
but I'm very happy to discuss it with my
right on befriend the minister for
Veterans Affairs and my honorable friend
and see what we can do on this matter
Owen Thompson Deputy speaker and I'd
like that the minister of what efforts
are going to take through the the
recently announced review of veterans
experiences and following on from the
excellent work of the old party group
for veteran survey of which I would draw
the chamber's attention to the fact I'm
a vice chair
um what attention we're going to pay to
the four nations different experiences
of veterans to make sure that we get the
best possible outcomes that sadly appear
to at the moment in many cases have been
overlooked and ignored you're here
um well I'm grateful to The Honorable
gentleman I look forward to seeing him
with his other co-chairs I think later
this week and we can discuss this matter
in in some depth I of course I'm
absolutely sympathetic to the the notion
that we need to do more for veterans of
course I am which is part of the reason
I have instituted the review to which I
have referred and we need to be
consciously aware of the experience the
lived experience and each one of the
four nations of this country
shut up Minister Rachel Hawkins
thank you mad and actually speaker a
review of Veteran Welfare Services is
long overdue but I might remind the
minister that it's his government that's
responsible for worsening Veterans
Services over the past 13 Years Veterans
mental health waiting times are a week
longer than last year veterans are
having to rely on charitable support
just to get by and Veteran ID cards are
nowhere to be seen for many action is
needed now to fix these failures so will
the minister tell the house when we can
expect the review to be completed and
its findings published
well I'm very grateful to The Honorable
lady and we're recruiting a person to
run this review right now and I
anticipate the review being completed
within three months if that gives her an
idea of timelines but can I just say
just so there's no misunderstanding
about this as an indication for the uh
appreciation or otherwise for the
services provided by vets UK there were
122 complaints since April last year
versus
1715 thank you letters so just to be
clear the people at Norcross who are
working on behalf of veterans I have
visited them she probably hasn't are
doing a sterling job and are highly
committed to what they do
Flora Anderson thank you madam Deputy
speaker question number five
uh Madam Deputy speaker with your
permission I should like to group
questions five and seven together the UK
has provided substantial support to our
NATO allies as we continue a United
response to Russia's aggression in
Ukraine over the last 12 months the
Royal Air Force has been deployed in
Romania and Lithuania across the
Mediterranean and has completed patrols
over the Black Sea we continue to
contribute to Nato air activity across
Europe the Army has been deployed in
Bulgaria Romania and Estonia where we
have our enhanced forward presence
battle groups the Royal Navy completed a
major European deployment from the North
Sea to the Mediterranean UK Armed Forces
continue to strengthen interoperability
with Finland and Sweden in anticipation
of their accession to Nato beyond the
U.S armed forces matter Deputy speaker
no nation has contributed more
can the minister tell us if the
government is working with
Nick to set up a full 2023 action plan
for Ukraine specifically for military
economic diplomatic and humanitarian
support to help give Ukraine confidence
in a sustained stream of future supplies
to urgently ramp up our own industry to
encourage allies to do more across NATO
and to make clear to Putin that things
will get worse not better for Russia
well Madam Deputy speaker The Honorable
lady asked an excellent question but I
hope she'll she won't mind if I just
make an important distinction NATO is
not involved in the planning and direct
support of the Ukrainian war effort and
it's a really important point to make
because Putin claims the exact opposite
to the Russian public and is entirely
wrong to do so those who support Ukraine
do so as an alliance of friends of
Ukraine out with NATO but of course NATO
is unbearably supportive of the work we
do she's right however to observe that
NATO does have a job of work to do to
both strengthen its eastern flank and to
provide a wider parents against any sort
of growth or escalation in the conflict
and of course in making sure that the
lessons of modern peer-ampere war
fighting in Ukraine are learned by the
entire Alliance and learn quickly
Let's Twist thank you madam Deputy
speaker now lover has fully backed moves
to bolster NATO allies in response to
the illegal evasion of Ukraine so can
the minister tell me what steps is the
UK taking to ensure our NATO obligations
to enhance forward presence are
completely fulfilled
well Madam Neptune speaker in the uh
immediate response to Russia's illegal
invasion of Ukraine we doubled the size
of the battle group in Estonia as a
further show of support to the Estonian
government and recognition of the
importance the enhanced war-present
battle group we've also contributed
contributed to efp uh battle groups in
Poland and in Romania in the last 12
months as well what will change and what
was the drought announced at The Summit
in Madrid is that there will be a new
NATO Regional defense plan which will be
an evolution of the in place enhanced
War presence battle groups alongside
National Defense plans of course the UK
will be very supportive of that in the
region that the uh that NATO assigned to
us but that is something that's very
much under review in the UK looks
forward to hearing NATO's detail once
it's finished working out
Stephen crap Deputy speaker following
the very successful Franco British
Summit at the end of last week which was
the fruit of enormous cross-government
effort does the minister agree with me
that renewing the bilateral defense
partnership with France which is the
second largest European contributor to
Nato is an important part of not just
strengthening the NATO alliance but
enhancing European security particularly
in East
I really do and it's noteworthy that
whilst relations elsewhere in government
may have been slightly more fraught
within the UK and French mod the
relationship has remained very tight and
necessarily so the interdependence that
the UK and France has is very obvious
our industrial collaboration is
widespread and will grow as a
consequence of the summit last week and
it's not just in the uh Far East that
the UK and France can work together but
also in West Africa where our interests
lie very keenly as well
they asked us on question six
speaker we are driving delivery of
capability to the front line the
majority of our programs are delivering
on time and on budget the second year
row under my stewardship the ministry of
Defense has set out an affordable
10-year equipment plan to make sure that
we're giving our Armed Forces what they
need whilst living within their means
yeah that's just
defense procurement is essential for the
success of a domestic steel industry and
the secretary of state will know that
the UK is the only country in the G20
where steel production is declining at
present steel is a vital industry of
National Security importance so will we
ensure that we do not get a repeat of
what happened with the fleet solid
support contract or an overseas lead
contractor has no obligation to use UK
Steel in the construction of UK Navy
ships yeah yeah
all right where we can we always strive
to use as much UK steel and when we
don't it's often because we don't
manufacture that type of Steel and we
have to do that uh uh because of the
necessity of using a seal in a certain
type of product look look the future
still a sportship whether navanti are
part of the Consortium or not you
shouldn't really listen to the union
briefing uh what he'll find is that
across the uh provision of that there
will be plenty of British components in
fact a majority uh will be a British
components as will the full integration
of that ship in a yard in Northern
Ireland
done will the Secretary of State update
the house on the status of the Ajax
procurement program where it's my
understanding that the supply chain is
being geared up to produce 589 Vehicles
yeah
so uh my ride on my friend will know the
Ajax was obviously uh decided upon in
March 2010 I think under the uh party
opposite and it has been as I've often
described it a troubled program since I
have taken over this office almost on a
weekly basis and with the determination
of both the former military defense
procurement and the current and we have
sought to rectify the issue the the
vehicle has now passed its user
validation trials and is now on its
basic field trials and is doing
extremely well I get a weekly update uh
also I think the house should be aware
that of course while the program is
delayed and we are doing our best to
rectify that overall it hasn't cost a
single extra Penny because a contract
which was made under this government or
under the conservative Government after
the selection of the vehicle by the
party opposite was a fixed price so yes
it's delayed but we are getting on it we
are fixing it and it's showing good
progress
Kevin Jones
can I first say it's Secretary of State
if he's going to quote the Nea he should
read the entire statement rather than
just selectively uh from it but can I
ask him in terms of Defense procurement
in the private sector uh in large multi
multi-billion pound contracts there's
usually a Project Lead put in place with
an expertise for a number of years
compare that to defense procurement
where we have well-meaning and
committing individuals who are there for
a short period of time with very little
expertise in project management is it
now time not to look at ways in which we
actually project manage these large
multi-million multi-year contracts and
get away from what the it appears to
some from amateur's approach to a more
professional approach but I I don't
disagree with some of my the right
honorable German observations that a
consistency in these programs is
incredibly important and as he and will
know some of these programs even when on
track can be 20-year programs and that
consistently is important but it isn't
just the sros and obviously those
programs are led by and he is right and
we are seeking to see if we can make
longer term uh or more permanent sros it
is also there accompanied by program
deliverers from the DNS obviously done
in Bristol and they are more permanent
but I think there are lots of lessons to
be learned about procurement some of
them are within our gift to fix some of
them have sadly been observed as
problems for decades you only have to
read numerous reports under his last
government and my government to know
that they have not always been rectified
some of them are out of our control such
as either inflation change of threat
change of technology or International
Consortium where you obviously have less
control when you start like the typhoon
obviously it's a four Nation project and
it's harder to sometimes control that
but overall I think the key in my
experience at Madame Deputy speaker is
first of all that we've got to manage
our expectations get our pricing right
and also seek that consistency of skills
and reward that skill base for the long
term and I would agree with him entirely
on that but
Alex shelbrook thank you Commander
Deputy speaker I want my right friend
agree with me that defense procurement
is a complex issue but it is not a total
disaster is often presented and that
when we compare Naval procurement to
some of our closest allies for example
the United States who ended up spending
five billion dollars per destroy in the
Xavier class while the Canadians who
took over 30 years to procure ship that
actually Naval procurement and the mod
producing type 26's type 31s under a
fixed price aircraft carriers come to
killer submarines and more actually
shows that the mod does try to do its
best in always tight Financial
circumstances
I'm grateful tomorrow and he served
obviously with me in the department and
I obviously miss his time in that
department the biggest driver to cost
overrun one of the biggest is the
decision to defer by the government of
the day to put off decisions about
whether they should cut something or
delete something deferring the aircraft
carrier under the party opposite cost a
billion pounds deferring the F-35 by
Under This government cost about 500
million if you defer things you cost
more in the long run that's always the
battle that the mod has with the
treasury and others that's fundamentally
one of the challenges one of the cost
drivers for many other projects they are
delivered on time they are delivered
successfully and our men and women armed
forces have some of the world leading
equipment they need to do their job
Shadow Minister Chris Evans thank you
madam desk and can I join other voices
in welcoming you back to your position
Madam Deputy speaker I think I speak on
behalf of everyone when I say the house
has missed your ability to turn people
to storm with a few words when they'll
follow the rules in this place
much of the innovation in the defense
industry comes from the SME sector
however many tell me there are real
barriers to enter and gain access to
government contracts and when they do
they find some primes are slow to pay
especially when projects are delayed
this has left them demotivated
demoralized and with a poor experience
of working with the ministry of Defense
how will ensure smes will have better
access and be encouraged to be involved
in a thriving British defense industry
well I I do recognize some of that
characteristic about smes have for
decades said there's a challenge about
engaging with wider government
procurement whether it's defense or
anything else I also recognize one of
the challenges is that obviously as the
guardian of the taxpayer risk involves
if you if you commission a small SME to
build something very large the amount of
risk they take in infrastructure is a
challenge and you can't go halfway
through a project without failing but I
do think the changes to the battlefield
is going to open much wider the aperture
for smes to be able to engage with
defense what we've seen in Ukraine
through operation Kindred is actually
the winners of that are actually the
smes the ability for us to cut through
the regulations that normally govern how
we procure because we're procuring for
someone else in a war zone has enabled
us to effectively go straight to those
marketplaces straight to smes and some
of the big Winners have been smes and
Innovation and space and we would we
therefore know the results whether they
work or not when they get to Ukraine I
think there is an exciting time I do
recognize that a narrative it's been
around since when I worked in the
Aerospace sector but of course we should
do more and must do and where we have a
big exciting project whether that's the
next generation of fighter aircraft the
gcap or when we had the carrier we had
the carrier Alliance sometimes it's
important that something sits over the
top to make sure these smbs are forced
in if the Prime's get in the way
Alex Norris number eight Please Mum
Deputy speaker
permission Madam Deputy speaker I should
like to answer questions 8 9 and 20
together I look forward to the outcome
of the review and Welfare Services cited
earlier but in the meantime over 40
million is being invested by the mod to
digitize all paper-based practices in
pre-processes and to create a single
entry point for pensions and
compensation by the end of 2024. we have
successfully launched a new digital
claim service for compensation pension
schemes making it easier for our people
to process their claims over time that
will make a very big difference
question 20 has in fact been withdrawn
Alex Norris thank you modern Deputy
speaker and the Minster mentions the the
review underway there is of course a
review already underway into the Armed
Forces compensation scheme with its
initial findings saying that so far the
processes are burdensome and even
distressing for the claim of which is
especially concerning since there's been
a fall and successful claims from 66 to
47 I wonder if the minister might
confirm that that review is still
ongoing when it might report and what
you think he thinks is going on here
well for that he is correct uh that the
the final report will be delivered
within I hope a few weeks
um so you'll have to await the
government's response to that of course
but it actually does tie in with some of
the findings of the appg group for
veterans which we discussed earlier on
and I am concerned about any reports
that the service isn't as as good as it
really ought to be so I will be taking
uh that review and the appg's findings
extremely seriously but I'm bound to
cite the uh 122 complaints versus
1715 thank you letters which I find
persuasive in forming a conclusion that
the people working for vets UK are
working hard and doing their very best
under quite difficult circumstances in
the interests of the people who serve
and have served our country yeah
Dame Angela Eagle thank you very much um
and it's uh great to see you back in the
chair away
um on the Armed Forces compensation
schemes Queen Colonial review my own
constituents have had similar problems
trying to engage with it they find it
slow to make decisions very difficult to
engage with and not really user-friendly
so I hope that when the minister does
publish the findings of this review
he'll come back to this house and
explain how he's going to make this
system much easier for veterans to
engage with because at the moment my own
constituents have told me that it's very
very difficult indeed here yes I'm
grateful to the right old lady she's
right to raise this we're increasingly
digitizing the services as I said
earlier on I can't understate how
important that is if you go to Norcross
and see the mountains of paperwork that
that that organization question is is is
having to cope with you begin to
understand how vitally important it is
that we properly digitize it and bring
the service into the 21st century which
we're intent on doing she may like to
know because it gives us again a bit of
a barometer a bit of a litmus on on how
the service is doing that the proportion
of cases appeal there's to say to the
tribunal under the Armed Forces
compensation scheme has been falling
since 2014-15 and I take that as some
measure perhaps to balance some of the
remarks to be made to the country uh
that that vets UK is is not up is not up
to scratch but we do need to review it
that's what we're doing and I'm I'm
absolutely convinced the service going
forward will be better than it is at the
moment if that's of any reassurance the
Arab lady
thank you we now move on to topical
questions Mr Aleister Carmichael we call
number two please
speaker today's questions have rightly
focused on support for our friends in
Ukraine but it's important to remember
that threats are also going elsewhere in
the world the Middle East continues to
Harbor terrorism which is why the UK
still supports the government of Iraq as
part of the global Coalition against I
want to update the house on a strike
that took place a few weeks ago as is
our agreement on strike such a round of
Shader in late December an RAF Reaper
remotely piloted aircraft conducted a
strike against a leading daesh member in
alabab Northern Syria the individual's
activity was related to chemical and
biological weapons the Reaper's crew
minimized potential risk to civilians
before firing two Hellfire method
missiles both of which struck the target
accurately action like these are vital
to degrading terrorist threats
protecting British students and
supporting our International partners
oh let's Circle Monaco I keep Mountain
Dew speaker I think we can all accept
that there is a legitimate rule for the
security services in combating
disinformation campaigns from foreign
hostile States but a recent report from
the campaign Big Brother watch showed
that in 2020 a number of British
citizens I had their social media posts
featured in monitoring reports produced
for the cabinet office by the British
army 77th Brigade so can the Secretary
of State tell the house is the 77th
Brigade still monitoring social media
posts and British citizens and if they
are for what purpose and under what
Authority
um the role of something some Brigade in
one part of this role is to challenge a
disinformation not opinion it is not its
role to monitor opinion or indeed to
counter that that is for the freedom
that we all enjoy in our society but it
is uh does do a role of being on the
lookout for what you would call uh uh
you know media manipulation of
misinformational lies from abroad and
where that is that is found that is
flagged to the appropriate authorities
I'm very happy to write them with Fuller
details about what legal authorities
they function but I can assure him at
any stage if I see anything that I think
crosses out of that line I have in
writing made sure that is known and that
has stopped
sir Julian Lewis welcome back Madam
Deputy speaker it's great to see you I
was going to put to my right honorable
friend the Secretary of State uh the
statistics that he's heard many times
about the proportions of GDP spent on
defense both during and after the Cold
War they're a lot higher than the
present day but may I instead ask him to
bear in mind when negotiating with the
treasury that any investment made in
defense now for purposes of conventional
deterrence will be minuscule compared
with what we would have to spend if
heaven forbid the war with Ukraine
escalated into a war with NATO so this
is an investment it is not expenditure
that should be likely considered but it
is essential for our future security
speaker I completely concur with my
right honorable friend that you know
defense is not a discretionary spend
it's not an add-on it is a core function
of any state especially this government
I have been very grateful since 2020
that we have turned that corner and
started to rebuild that momentum the
extra money that I've got for this week
is continuing that momentum but he is
absolutely right the important here is
that deterrence is actually cheaper than
having to go and fight the war if it
goes wrong look at the cost of people of
Ukraine look at the cost of their
economy and we really need to make
people change that culture the culture
that we have got used to probably since
the early 90s that somehow defense is
discretionary it isn't and please the
Prime Minister and also when he was
chanter 2020 recognize that and we need
to carry on on that trajectory
Shadow Secretary of State John Healy
the house will be thankful and grateful
to the defense secretary for updating it
on the latest up Shader activity and if
there are any questions that can't be
raised this afternoon we will return to
them on tonight's orcas announcement in
San Diego does a defense certainly
recognize this has Labor's fullest
support we want Britain to play the
biggest possible role in building the
new Australian submarines but beyond the
subs how will the defense secretary
develop the pillar 2 collaboration on
Artificial Intelligence on Cyber and on
Hypersonic missiles
I might have just big I'm grateful to
the right honorable gentleman's support
for orcas August is a decades-long
commitment and when people talk about
procurement challenges you know when you
start this journey of submarines they
will be delivered in 2030s 2040s some of
them will go on to the 2050s it's not a
journey you can stop halfway along or
indeed stop for a break and and you know
go back to the right-hand of a
gentleman's friends comments earlier
sometimes I think parts of the treasury
struggle with that concept so I'm
grateful for the extra money orcas
pillar 2 is incredibly important it is
about next Generations technology one of
the most important works we are doing
and we met in the Pentagon in December
is to clear away the itar challenges
that's so for so many years has held us
back in being able to share our own
technology with the United States or
indeed collaborate properly to make a
step change to give us the Strategic
Advantage we need we're going to be
working on that and I'm very happy to
brief them in detail on the future of
the pillar 2.
Andrews Deputy speaker France is uh
closer security pardon other than the
United States so can my right honorable
friend date the house on his meeting
with his French counterpart and how will
we continue to ensure that historic
defense partnership is ready to take on
the threats of the future
one of a friend is is incredibly right
to point out how important France is to
us France is our our main partner in
Europe it is a similar size Armed Forces
with a similar expeditionary a status
and indeed uh ambition uh I speak to my
colleague almost every two weeks
sometimes every week I spoke to him
twice including last week when I visited
in the beginning so a partnership we
worked on was more of the sea Jeff
that's the combined joint expeditionary
force that we work with them training
and exercising together more work on
complex weapons through mbdna which is a
great International Consortium with a
factory obviously in Bolton and
stevenage and working together to make
sure we have the same requirements we
need and also in shared operations and
where we can work together in areas such
as West Africa where British and French
interest and European interests are
under threat from the likes of Wagner
I'm grateful to the Secretary of State
for giving such thorough answers which
I'm quite sure that the house
appreciates but now I would ask him to
be a little quicker because it would be
good if we managed to get everybody in
Ruth Jones thank you madam Deputy
speaker and it's good to see you back in
your rightful place
um Labor's dossier of waste in the mod
has founded at least 15 billion pounds
has been wasted in taxpayers money since
2010. so can the minister explain to the
people in my constituency of Newport
West why this Tory government is failing
to get a grip in of the defense
procurement process and failing to
secure value for money for the taxes
they pay
I would Point her constituents to the
2010 National Audit office report of her
government that gave some really
interesting clues about why procurement
was so bad it it said here the
department under her government
contracted for aircraft carriers when it
knew it wasn't affordable or perhaps the
Public Accounts committee chaired by the
right honorable lady for barking who who
actually said delays and cancellation to
progo programs this is about the land
systems under her government have
revealed in gaps and armored vehicles
capability that will not be filled into
2025. I think there's lots of clues for
her constituents which you should just
direct them to those reports
Deputy speaker and can I too say it's
great to see you back in your place
second estate I'll try and keep this
brief the the Clive Sheldon KC review
Into the management information
surrounding Ajax has been with the
Department I think for over a month now
given its importance can the Secretary
of State
guarantee that one it will be published
by the east of assess and two it will be
published fully unredacted
I thank the right honorable gentleman
for his uh concerned proper concern
about this issue the Sheldon review was
and is entirely independent of
government and provided an initial draft
to the mod at the end of January since
then Mr Sheldon has been conducting a
fact-checking and maxwellization
exercise as part of the final stages of
drafting the time frame in an
independent review is not a matter for
the Department once received however I
can say it will be published with all
Expedition accompanied by a statement to
the house
good to see you in your place the Prime
Minister spoke to journalists earlier on
today about the integrated review
refresh so we already know that there's
no target for reaching the 2.5 percent
of GDP for defense spending and that the
Army is not going to get the 3 billion
it needs to avoid making further cuts is
this a good deal for defense yeah yeah
well I think first of all I'm not sure
where he gets there he won't get three
percent to avoid the cuts at the moment
it'll be a decision off the balance
Investments you'll see in the command
paper about how we apportion uh any
savings that we have to make as a result
of inflation but overall as I've said
our equipment program and indeed our
envelope is on track subject to the
inflation pressures and extra
operational commitments that we have
been making he will also be aware that
of course we've had an extra 560 million
on top of that for restocking of
ammunition and we've also had
commitments for the treasury on new for
old and much of the gifting so I believe
that the Army will be in a good State
throughout this process and I'll make
sure that when it comes to the Defense
command paper he gets a full readout of
why and how we make those decisions
could I ask my honorable friend what
steps his department is taking to
support smes in the defense sector who
are being adversely affected by the
application of the environmental social
and governance criteria which is making
it very difficult for them to raise
Capital to invest in their business and
expand yes my only friend is a champion
of smes and he's absolutely right to be
so because they're at the heart of a
vibrant and flexible UK defense industry
and that's why this department helps
fund find and fund exploitable ideas
from smes but to his point there is
nothing contradictory between the
principles of ESG and the defense
industry on the contrary strong National
Defense is the ultimate guarantor of the
freedoms which all too often are taken
for granted human rights democracy and
the international rules-based order
speaker speaker and this is good to see
you in your place
Madam Deputy speaker thousands of
retired Gurkha soldiers who left the
Army before 1997 live in very
considerable poverty many my
constituency I understand there's
ongoing negotiations between the
department and I think upon the ministry
and the Government of Nepal and I'd be
grateful if the secretary of state or a
minister could update you on this
important issue
well I'm grateful to The Honorable
gentleman uh he probably will know that
recently I set up a joint committee uh
chaired by me and The Nepalese
ambassador to consider outstanding
Gurkha welfare issues I have to tell him
that retrospective pension changes in
respect to the gurkhas have been through
the system several times including the
high court the Supreme Court and the
European judicial institutions and the
position which is long-standing with the
UK government has been upheld but I am
Keen to make sure we do everything in
our power to ensure that gurkhas and
Gurkha veterans living in the UK and in
Nepal are given the very best we
reasonably can to support their welfare
Danny Krueger thank you
very pounds to resupply the Armed Forces
for the Munitions and the equipment that
has been sent to Ukraine this is very
positive news and I also welcome up my
one representative Secretary of State
said about the importance of investing
in Army accommodation that will be very
welcome to my constituents in tidworth
Buford and Lark Hill but in the spirit
of honesty which he spoke about could
you tell us what he thinks it would take
to convince the treasury that we must do
more than simply resupply our armed
forces and then we need a bigger Army
not a smaller one
but I I don't need to do much more to
convince them the chancellor said in the
Autumn statement as did the Prime
Minister that they recognize that
defense would need more spending I think
they have crossed that line and and they
already knew that the chance to prime
minister he was Chancellor he gave us
the extra 24 billion and indeed the
current chance and if you remember still
on a platform for a greater percentage
of GDP when he was standing for
leadership of the conservative party I
think the key here is now to make sure
we lock it in uh to get the a long a
time frame so that we can start the
investment and planning that's going to
be required at the next comprehensive
spending review and Beyond
speaker great to see you back at your
place um to be fair to the defense
secretary he's been very candid the 13
years of this government has in his
words hollowed out and underfunded are
armed forces but why should anyone
believe that the government that
underfunded it over 13 years should in
its final gasps this exhaustive
government will actually put right the
hollowing out that it's put in place
over this last 13 years yeah
maybe the right on them I can't hear I
didn't say 13 I said 30 years of
hollowing out which includes his last
government a government I was a soldier
serving under mainly because his
government spent a lot of money going to
war in the Middle East and that hollowed
us out as well because we weren't
properly refunded the reality is if he
wanted to come to this house and start a
debate about defense I'd really
appreciate if he came here with a bit of
Candor about his own government's role
in it we've done that I've had the
courage to do it maybe he might
Elliot cold Madam Deputy speaker can I
begin by thanking Castleton and
Wallington residents who have opened
their homes to Ukraine but can I ask my
right now offend for some assurance that
the kit we are sending to Ukraine will
indeed come with a specialist support
and training needed to operate it
we have uh obviously in the United
Kingdom thousands of British Armed
Forces joined by Canadians Norwegians
Dutch Swedish
lithuanians uh United uh Australians and
New Zealand endless numbers of people
helping them with that training we also
make sure that not only do they train
there when they're going to somewhere
like Germany they're now getting
combined arms training it's really
important that training companies
equipment and where we've just we've had
feedback we've corrected the training as
well
Barry Sherman I've been Deputy speaker I
really missed it can I also the
Secretary of State what do you make of
what presidency has been saying over the
last few days and I will urge him to
take it that he must not do but people
are rooming he might do given the
present situation that he might be
thinking about resigning will he stay
with us but fight for more money for our
Armed Forces oh
well I mean I think about him next week
is a Tory you think about resigning most
the time
I'm not interested I'm interested in
trying to uh uh over the years I'm
interested in trying to deliver for our
matter where the Armed Forces uh you
know I went into politics because the
men of women the Armed Forces needed
better deserve better and I'm determined
to try and stick that through uh but I'm
also worried about the direction of
threat for this country and for the
world not only what we've seen China as
I think they quoted equipping for War as
they announced last week we've seen 83.4
percent enriched uranium being
discovered with our iea is published in
their report that's weeks away from 90
weapons grade should that be a decision
I've seen a growing problem with Russia
and its violent extremism spreading
across Africa the threat is going up
across the world we're more anxious more
unstable and I think that means
long-term investment on whoever is the
government's over the next 10 15 years
final question flick Drummond
very much because it's lovely to see you
back as a former chair of the Southeast
region for the veterans advisory pension
committee I've seen it firsthand the
long shells at Norcross where veterans
UK is based so can the minister assure
me that the digitization of veterans
records will proceed quickly so the
veterans can get quick decisions on
their welfare and their welfare claims
well I'm very grateful to my honorable
friend and I pay tribute to her service
with the vapc
um she's been like I have to Norcross
and seen the extraordinary files of
paperwork and there's no way we can
provide a 21st century service that our
veterans deserve whilst things are in
that state so the 40 million pound
digitization though it may sound banal
with Mo will most certainly make a huge
difference and we will also be
addressing the other things which we can
that delay claims so I'm thinking
particularly if the difficulties we have
very often with our medical advisors are
getting reports from GPS in the NHS
that's one of the major hurdles I'm
afraid to getting these things dealt
with timely but I'm resolved that we
should do our level best to make sure
things are better going forward
thank you that concludes questions and
we are now about to Embark upon the
first I'm just pausing for a moment to
allow the change of cast on the front
benches
um we are
now about to Embark upon the first of
today's statements
from the foreign secretary on the
integrated review refresh foreign
secretary
Deputy speaker I smile because it is a
genuine Delight to see you back in this
house back in your place
um Madam speaker with permission I will
make a statement on the 2023 integrated
review refresh
two years ago the government's
integrated review set out a clear
strategy on how the UK would continue to
thrive in a far more competitive age
our approach is the most comprehensive
since the end of the Cold War it laid
out how we would bring together the
combined might of every part of
government to ensure that our country
remains safe prosperous and influential
into the 2030s
and the conclusions of that review have
run as a golden strategic thread through
all of our activities across defense and
deterrence diplomacy trade and
investment intelligence Security
International Development Science and
Technology over the last two years
our overall analysis was right
and our strategic ambition on track on
every continent of the world the United
Kingdom walks taller today than it has
done for many years
we are meeting our obligations as a
permanent member of the U.N security
Council and as a leading European Ally
with within an expanding NATO
we have strong relationships with our
neighbors in Europe and we will build on
the Windsor framework to invigorate them
even further we are deeply engaged in
the indo-pacific active in Africa and
enjoy thriving relationships with
countries in the Middle East and the
Gulf
now this house I'm sure will recall that
today is Commonwealth today Commonwealth
day and I'll be meeting my fellow
Commonwealth foreign ministers in London
over the course of this week
we have maintained our position as a
global leader on International
Development by pursuing patient
long-term Partnerships tailored to the
needs of our partner countries and we
succeed because those Partnerships draw
on the full range of UK strengths and
expertise in addition to our official
development assistance
and as this house will of course be
aware the severe Global turbulence
forecast in the 21 integrated review has
indeed come to pass but the events have
moved as an even quicker Pace than I
think anyone could have imagined just
two years ago Russia's full-scale
invasion of Ukraine and attempts to
Annex part of its Sovereign territory
challenge the entire International order
across the world State threats have
grown and systematic competition has
intensified
there is a growing Prospect or further
deterioration in the coming years
because of the far-reaching consequences
for the security and prosperity of the
British people that these changes have
brought it is right that I update the
house on what the government is doing to
respond
in our 2023 integrated review refresh we
set out how we respond to an even more
contested and volatile world
rightly our approach is an evolution not
a revolution
and I know this house will agree that
our most pressing foreign policy
priority is the threat that Russia's
full-scale invasion of Ukraine poses for
European security
the UK has provided huge quantities of
military support for Ukraine's defense
we led the G7 response on Ukraine
coordinating diplomatic activity and
working with our allies to impose the
toughest ever sanctions on Putin's
government
and thanks to the wisdom of this
government's original integrative review
we are intensified our training for
thousands of Brave Ukrainian troops who
repelled Russia's initial onslaught
must be maintained until Ukraine
prevails and The Wider threat that
Russia and other states such as Iran or
North Korea pose to the international
order to make sure that their aggression
is contained or potential aggression is
contained
the 2023 integrated review refresh also
sets out how the government will
approach the challenges presented by
China
China's size and significance connect it
to almost every Global issue
but we cannot be blind to the
increasingly aggressive military and
economic behavior of the Chinese
Communist party including stoking
tensions across the Taiwan Strait and
attempts to strong-arm Partners most
recently Lithuania
we will increase our national security
protections and ensure alignment with
both our core allies and a wider set of
international partners
and we must build on our own and our
allies resilience to cyber threats
manipulation of information economic
instability and energy shocks so that we
remain at the front of the race for
Technologies like fusion power that will
Define not only the next decade but the
rest of this century
Madam Deputy speaker my right honorable
friend the chancellor of the exchequer
will say more on government spending
commitments in his spring statement on
Wednesday but today I can set out a
number of both immediate and longer-term
measures that will help us deliver on
our priorities and they are as follows
we will increase defense spending by a
further 5 billion pounds over the next
two years this will bring us to around
two and a quarter percent of national
income and represents significant
progress in meeting our long-term
minimum defense spending Target of two
and a half percent of GDP
today's announcement of five billion
pounds comes on top of the commitments
made by the chancellor in his Autumn
budget statement
on top of the 560 million of new
Investments last year and on top of the
records 20 billion pound uplift
announced in 2020
later today the Prime Minister will
announce alongside President Biden and
prime minister albanazi the next steps
for orcus
including how we will deliver
multi-billion pound conventionally armed
nuclear-powered submarine capabilities
to the Royal Australian Navy while
setting the highest non-proliferation
standards
we will provide an additional 20 million
pound uplift to the BBC World Service
over the next two years protecting all
42 World Service language services
we have established a new directorate in
the fcdo incorporating the government
information cell to increase our
capacity to assess and counter hostile
information manipulation by actors
including Russia and China
where it affects UK interests overseas
well we will double funding for Chinese
expertise and capacities in government
so that we have more Mandarin speakers
and China experts and we all create a
new one billion pound Integrated
Security fund to deliver critical
programs at home and overseas on key
priorities like economic and cyber
security
counter-terrorism and on the battle to
uphold and defend human rights
we will establish a new National
Protective Services Authority located
within MI5 it will provide UK businesses
and other organizations with immediate
access to expert security advice
and a new 50 million powered economic
deterrence initiative will strengthen
sanctions enforcement and impact and it
will also give us new tools to respond
to hostile Acts we will be publishing
the UK's first semiconductor strategy
which will grow our domestic industry
for this vital technology as well as an
updated critical minerals strategy
the 2023 integrated review
reconfirms that the UK will play a
leading role in upholding stability
security and the prosperity of our
continent and the euro-atlantic as a
whole it underlines that this
government's investment in our
indo-pacific strategy is yielding
significant results across defense
diplomacy and trade Madam Deputy speaker
through these initiatives and many
others we have set out over the past two
years the United Kingdom will
out-compete those who seek to
destabilize the international order and
undermine global stability our approach
is imbued with the spirit of
international cooperation and a
pragmatic willingness to work with any
country that does not seek to undermine
our way of life we will live in a
competitive age and security challenges
the British people face today are the
most serious in at least a generation
time and again in our history
we have seen off the competition from
countries that wish to do us no good we
were able to do so because the United
Kingdom has always had more allies and
better allies than any of our rivals or
competitors this will always be the
policy of this government to ensure that
remains the case and I commend this
statement to the house
Shadow foreign secretary David
well Madam Deputy speaker it's very good
to see you in your place and can I thank
the foreign secretary for advanced site
of his statement just over a year ago
Russia's full-scale invasion of Ukraine
marked a watershed moment for European
Security in the time since 25 NATO
countries have Revisited their security
strategies Germany announced a
fundamental shift in its security policy
Finland and Sweden have taken the
historic decision to join NATO for a
year labor have urged the government to
revisit the integrated review so this
announcement today is overdue but it's
welcome
we are living in an era of intensifying
geopolitical competition in a
multi-polar world the interdependence of
the global economy is increasingly being
weaponized and there's been a blurring
of the distinction between foreign and
domestic policy this is a challenging
moment for our security and that of our
allies and for our place in the world
Madam Deputy speaker the refreshed
integrated review and the decisions it
will inform is therefore important to
all of us in this house we all have an
interest in the government making the
right long-term choices for our country
and any future labor government will
inherit the consequences of those
decisions since the Invasion the
government have had our fullest support
in providing the military economic and
diplomatic support for Ukraine to defend
itself but we've pressed the government
where they have fallen short and it's in
that spirit that we approach the review
today
the original integrated review contained
plenty of analysis that was sound and
which could enjoy wide support in this
house but it did have some serious
shortcomings it made no mention of the
risks of the Taliban taking over Kabul
just months before it happened nor did
it foresee the risks of a full-scale
invasion of Ukraine or mention risks
related to Taiwan it had little to say
about Europe Beyond NATO and said almost
nothing about the European Union which
has given
one substantive reference in the entire
document in too many areas from the
fight against kleptocracy to the
importance of international law rhetoric
and ambition contrasted poorly with
government inaction or hypocrisy
significant and regretful decisions like
the decision to cut the Oda spending to
0.5 percent of gni and the merger of
diffid and the fcdo were taken before
the review had even been concluded and
in security and defense there was a
clear mismatch between ends Ways and
Means with threats increasing and a
promise of persistent Global engagement
the government announced plans to cut
another 10 000 troops scrap Hercules
planes and drop the 148 Challenger tanks
these are the troops now reinforcing
NATO allies the planes used in the Kabul
air airlift and the tanks being used and
sent to Ukraine in the two years since
in too many areas the promises of the
integrated review have not matched
reality the so-called indo-pacific tilt
has apparently been completed but the
UK's diplomatic presence in key
countries in the region including India
and China has been cut by up to 50
percent over the past eight years the
review promised to maintain the UK as
one of the world's leading Development
actors but Aid not just has not just
been cut from 0.7 to October 0.5 it's
now being used to prop up the broken
Asylum system and by some estimates less
than half of bilateral development
assistance ever leaves the United
Kingdom rather than standing up for
international law we've had ministers
come coming to this chamber explaining
how they plan to break it successive
crisis from the pandemic to war in
Ukraine have demonstrated the
vulnerability of International Supply
chains but we've not seen a new
diplomatic drive to reflect the shifting
resourcing economy Britain is falling
seriously behind the United States chips
legislation will provide 52 billion in
subsidies for U.S chip manufacturers the
EU chipset will provide 43 billion euros
but the government has put aside just
700 000 pounds to commission a research
project and it still has not published
it's promised semiconductor strategy
today refresh is therefore an
opportunity to address these flaws and
reset the government's approach a test
of this integrated review review is how
it contributes to making Britain secure
at home and strong abroad and this is
how we will judge it the government will
continue to have Labor's full support
over Ukraine and to reinforce our NATO
allies Labor's commitment to Nato
remains and our commitment to Britain's
independent nuclear deterrence is total
Madam Deputy speaker the reviews
emphasis on building Partnerships and
alliances is welcome after a period of
drift away from multilateralism Britain
is always a stronger and more effective
Force for good when it works with others
and that's why Labor's foreign policy
vision is for a Britain reconnected and
I'm glad the government have been taking
notes uh nowhere has the sense of
disconnection been stronger than in our
post-brexit relationship with the
European Union it is good that from page
22 to see the government finally
acknowledge its importance labor would
go further and seek a security pact to
cooperate on global challenges and keep
us safe on China we recognize the scale
and complexity of the challenge that its
rise represents and the breadth of our
interests that are at stake the
initiative to improve understanding of
China in government is vital
particularly given the foreign office
has only been training 14 people a year
to speak fluent Mandarin we need a
strong clear-eyed and consistent
approach to China working with partners
and allies and engaging with China where
our interests uh to where our interests
align to do so
it feels after years of inconsistent and
shifting approaches this is at least
something that we can now welcome it's
good to see a new economic deterrence
unit to help enforce sanctions as
mentioned on page 48 because not a
single individual or entity has been
fined for breaching Russia's sanctions
since the invasion not one sanctions
without enforcement are useless and I
note the plan for a new Russia strategy
but the government hasn't yet
implemented all of the Russia reports
recommendations on Iran the government
is right to recognize the increasing
threat so it was disappointing that they
opposed our amendment to create a new
mechanism to prescribe hostile State
actors like the irgc
and in an era of disinformation the BBC
World Service is a unique and
unparalleled platform and so the
additional funding is very welcome
however on defense spending today's
announcement provides only funds for
orcas and Ukraine's replenishment that
is why we welcome it
it does not answer growing questions
concerning capability gaps that weaken
our National Defense and undermine
yuko's NATO contribution the Nao
recently said that the mod cannot afford
to develop all the capabilities set out
in the 2021 integrated review how does
today's announcement ensure the same
doesn't happen now the new 2023
integrated review has been published the
reality is that the government are
dragging their feet on the big decisions
the long-term goal to spend 2.5 percent
of GDP on defense sounds I'm afraid a
little Hollow promise there's no plan
and there's no timetable I can tell him
that the last Labor government left
office with 2.5 percent of the spent
defense spending intact the reality is
that too much of the government's ethics
is focused on undoing its mistakes The
Windsor framework to fix the protocol
they negotiated a Franco British Summit
to repair relations damaged by his
predecessor's clumsy diplomacy a 16.5
billion investment defense swallowed up
by a black hole in the budget they
mismanaged removing the Chinese State
role in our nuclear power industry after
the Government invited them in the first
place and trying to strengthen our
leadership in International Development
after the government squandered it we
welcome this refresh but we will
continue to provide robust scrutiny
where necessary to ensure that our
country's foreign policy and defense
systems are secure for the Next
Generation
Deputy speaker I'm not a religious man
but I understand there is a phrase in
the Bible there's more joy in heaven
over a sinner that repents
and it's really good
to hear it's really I I say I'm not a
religious man
because I am joyful I am joyful that
labor front bench has finally perhaps
Kicking and Screaming uh come to the
realization that all the time uh that uh
all the time let's take a let's take a
official development assistance Madam
speaker
this um this government at its lowest
point is still spending a larger portion
of its GDP than at the highest point
under the party opposite when they were
in government I remember I remember I
remember when the Russian state was
instrumental in poisoning British
citizens and the leader of the party
opposite at the time was saying we
should share our intelligence with the
very state that was poisoning British
people I am now glad finally to hear
a commitment from the label up front
bench about maintaining the nuclear
deterrent about uh support for uh NATO
um and it's interesting that we are
being criticized it's interesting that
we are being criticized for uh getting
our defense spending to uh to two and a
quarter percent of GDP with the
commitment to 2.5 percent of GDP because
I hear no such commitment formally from
the defense Shadow defense team on the
bench opposite the simple truth of the
matter is that the honorable gentleman
what has made a a number of a number of
points about what they would do
differently whilst then saying but
broadly he agrees with this strategy and
I'm glad that he agrees with his
strategy because we have been working on
it for last we've been implementing the
2001 integrated review and we have seen
we have seen the positive impact it has
had on our relations in the indo-pacific
the signing of the joint the fcas
agreement between Italy Japan and the
United Kingdom is Testament in fact the
fact that the carrier strike groups made
in Voyage was into that region is
Testament to that and the fact that we
are seeing absolutely at the Forefront
of the international support to Ukraine
in their self-defense or against
Russia's invasion is Testament to that
this government will always be an
internationally focused government it
will always make sure that we act in
close concert with our International
partners and we'll build greater
Partners around the world that's what
this refresh is about it builds on the
work of the original integrated review
and I'm very proud we put it in the
public domain yeah
chair of the select committee Alicia
care
it is a joy to see you back in your
place I welcome much of this pragmatic
refresh and it is good to see Foreign
Affairs committee recommendations
Embrace such as making resilience a key
pillar the Mandarin capability Cricket
criticality of critical minerals
deterrence diplomacy and the importance
of Science and Technology however the
threat of China cannot be seen primarily
as an economic one because to do so is
to fail to recognize that they are
trying to undermine our security and our
sovereignty so the asks are greater
resolve when dealing with transnational
oppression that means shutting down the
illegal Chinese police stations and
closing down the Iranian regime's
cutouts which are operating uh in London
and across our country I welcome the
creation of the national protective
security authority to tackle techno
authoritarianism but this is support for
the private sector and I hope therefore
the government will accept my Amendment
for support to public sector uh
procurement when the procurement Bill
comes forward in a couple weeks time and
finally the government right he talks
about the Reconstruction of Ukraine in
the refresh will he now commit to use
frozen Central Bank funds the government
seems to claim that we don't have the
law in place to do this although it's
not legally tested tell us what normal
change you need we will make it and
let's test it in the courts
Saturday
Mr Speaker
um thank you for that give that
Adrenaline Rush that one needs at
dispatch well
um the uh my honorable my honorable
friend uh the chair of the select
committee uh has uh highlighted a number
of uh important areas in her question
today and I recommend her and the
committee for the work that they have
done in putting forward ideas uh which
we always take seriously and the fact
that she recognizes uh some of the
conversations or some of the thinking
that her committee has put forward woven
into this uh is by no accident we always
listen to the constructive feedback from
colleagues from whatever side of the
house they come from
um we are very conscious that the threat
from uh Chinese activities not just on
the economic sphere I can assure her
that in terms of our security uh not
just Economic Security we are absolutely
thinking it'll cost the full range of of
of threats and risks but also of course
we have to recognize that there is the
need and opportunity to engage with
China on the areas where we can work
more um successfully
I can assure her I can assure her that
when it comes to uh protecting ourselves
um against the uh risks in that economic
sphere it will not just be limited to
the private sector and we will of course
look to give advice to the private
sector and more broadly but I can assure
her we will continue to think across the
full range of threats and risks
a seven piece spokesperson Drew head
right thank you thank you Mr Speaker and
while she's still in the chamber can I
also welcome back that Madame Deputy
speaker please nice to see you up here
can I also thank the foreign secretary
for advanced uh site of his statement
and there are some things to welcome
from the review that are very clear the
funding for the BBC World Service I
think everyone can say that's a good
move to see measures the tackle and
counter hostile information manipulation
are also uh things that we should be
doing good to see in there and it's
sensible to develop more expertise on
China although there are gaps in the uh
the strategy for China it's also
painfully obvious
um that we needed a reassessed Russia
strategy so that is something that it's
important to come forward with in detail
and the support for Ukraine must be
ongoing and I would repeat the call for
frozen assets to be used in the
rebuilding process
um but I think the minister also needs
to reflect on where his golden thread
has freed they've been flat-footed in
the crisis over Afghanistan and there's
still the issue of British Council
workers so what lessons have been
learned from the future from that
tobacco what are his Ambitions uh in
rebuilding with the EU and where is the
detail on dealing with the global
climate crisis it's barely mentioned in
the documents internationally it should
not be used as a trade lever and yet
that's still part of the UK government's
plans
and increase military spending needs
more detail what when will that come to
the house security expert Edward Lucas
has warned Britain's military cannot
sustain a global rule describing UK
Armed Forces as a clapped out Army
serious problems with our Naval vessels
and an Air Force short of planes and
Pilots now the presence of nuclear
weapons and NATO countries did not deter
Putin from invading Ukraine why would
spending more on new nuclear be a good
idea now does he agree that spending in
conventional areas would be better than
wasting on nuclear or is it just the
fact that the 5.5 billion pound shambles
of the Ajax tanks procurement has left
them afraid of this kind of investment
Thursday
uh Mr Speaker when it comes to who is
ultimately going to pay for the terrible
damage that we see across Ukraine it is
absolutely right that the aggressor pays
and we will of course work closely with
our International Partners to make sure
that those that cause the damage repair
the damage the exact vehicle for doing
so is one that will of course be
discussed and decided internationally
because it demands an international
response
I think he's drawn very much the wrong
lessons when he comes to the nuclear
deterrent he says he says that NATO
having nuclear weapons didn't prevent
Russia attacking Ukraine bearing in mind
of course that Ukraine is not a member
of NATO and Ukraine gave up its nuclear
weapons Arsenal and it was Russia's
failure to abide by the commitments made
in the mint agreement
um and uh I mean he he says it didn't
stop invading Ukraine Ukraine is not a
member of NATO I can draw him a map I
can draw a map if it helps Ukraine is
not a member of NATO our nuclear
deterrent is absolutely at the
foundation stone of the Euro Atlantic
defense and the UK will always abide by
its commitment to its friends and
Neighbors in the region
and we will of course ensure that the
standing that we currently enjoy as
being one of the most uh uh significant
contributors to the euro Atlantic uh
defense relationship is maintained and
enhanced both in terms of our
nuclear deterrent but also in our
conventional means as well
Mr Speaker
defense posture matters if we want to
play a role on the international stage
then a hard power counts and we have to
be honest the last integrated review
review saw swathing cuts to our land sea
and air assets which many I think in the
house we're hoping would be reversed
today page nine of the review summarizes
the threat there is a grain prospect
that the International Security
environment will further deteriorate in
the coming years with State threats
increasing and diversifying in Europe
and Beyond the risk of escalation is
greater than any time in decades Mr
Speaker we're sliding towards a new Cold
War threats are increasing yet here we
are staying on a peacetime budget I
asked my right all my friend he's got
two days before the budget is announced
please can we move to 2.5 GDP now
so to stay
uh Mr Speaker we have committed to 2.5
of GDP as a sustainable uh Baseline we
have announced we have announced that
additional 5 billion to uh to address
the immediate impact of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine as I said that is on
top of the 20 billion uplift that was
announced in uh 2020 and the uh over
half a billion that was of new
investment that was announced last year
we will of course continue to work with
our International allies to ensure that
our Collective defense posture uh is one
that genuinely deters aggression against
NATO and its member states and we have
been successful in doing that but of
course we will as this document has done
assess the likely impossible threats and
make sure that our defense posture
aligns to them
where
shouldn't have been slogans to Global
Britain are fine but without the
resources behind them they're pretty
meaningless the government between 2010
to the 21 caught the defense budget by
now he announced today a 5 billion pound
increase in defense budget and if you
look at social media they've promises
all over it uh trumpeting this
the defense secretary says that you need
11 he told the defense committee I sit
on to just stand still it's interesting
he's not here uh to defend that uh quote
but can I ask about the five billion
pounds uh three billion pounds is going
to be circled on the nuclear turn is
that new money or is that part of the
existing uh 10 billion which was put
aside for the uh defense the deterrent
already and if that leaves two billion
pounds additional expenditure that's a
long way from the defense secretaries
claiming that we need 11 even just to
stand still
Thursday Mr Speaker of the sexiest state
of defense was just at the just just at
this dispatch box welcoming the uh
welcoming the money he has left because
he's gone because he's gone to Japan
with whom we have recently signed a
defense agreement for the next
generation of fighter aircraft uh so so
so the slightly childish and raucous
calls from the front bench would
probably have a bit more impact were it
not for the fact but on this side of the
house we are actually getting on with
building those International
relationships building those defense
relationships that will keep us safe
keep our neighbors safe and keep our
friends safe right the way across the
globe Henry Smith thank you very much Mr
Speaker I very much welcome the
commitments to spend two and a half
percent of GDP on defense and also the
recommitment with our American and
Australian allies uh to Orcas uh can I
seek an assurance that there will be an
absolute alignment of our defense
defense and foreign policy postures and
positions to make sure that Global
Britain is delivering in the way that it
must for our own freedom and for our
allies
very steak
my honorable friend makes a very very
important point and this is why we have
now moved to integrated reviews
recognizing that uh defense diplomacy
International Development trade policy
all these things are interwoven and to
have a truly effective International
posture all these functions of
government and close coordination with
non-uh government organizations like the
BBC World Service for example all these
things uh need to go hand in hand which
is why we had the integrated review in
21 had this refresh integrated review
today and I can assure him and the whole
of the house that we will continue to
work in a closely coordinated manner
across government in order to deliver it
Liam
speaker thank can I welcome what I
thought heard was the recognition that
when it comes to China we need to do far
more to defend our values while
recognizing that there are Global public
goods that we need to work on together
like climate change nuclear
proliferation in the Pacific and Global
development too but since the last
integrated review the so-called tilt to
the Intel Pacific has entailed three
million extra in fcvo staff
three extra British High Commissioners
in the Pacific two extra warships and
under one percent of the mod head count
that's that's not a tilt that's a glance
in the right direction so can the
foreign secretary tell us how big is
this package going to be to finance what
should be the till needed to an area of
4.3 billion people
he seems to uh
I think embedded in his question seems
to be the idea that our postures to the
indo-pacific is a one-off event it's not
it is a permanent recalibration of our
foreign and defense policy uh my first
my first set of bilateral meetings my
first set of bilateral visits as foreign
secretary was to Japan South Korea and
to Singapore let's say the foreign
secretary is flying to Japan at the
moment to build upon the agreement that
we have made with did I say the defense
secretary the defense secretary the
defense secretary is flying to Japan uh
the French sector is flying to Japan to
follow up on the agreement that has been
made between the UK the uh Italian
government and the Japanese government
so the commitment that we've made is a
long-term commitment and it is being
resourced the the the fact that carrier
strike groups made in voyageables to the
region all these things are building
towards what is a permanent
recalibration of our International Focus
to recognize the center of gravity of
world affairs is moving eastwards and
moving southwards and we are responding
to that well Francois thanks speaker I
welcome the foreign secretary's Crystal
Clear commitment but from 2025 we will
spend 2.5 percent of our GDP on defense
I'd be interested to know whether labor
will match it but part of that spending
also referred to in the document is the
orcus program which will be a
world-class collaboration between the
United States ourselves and Australia
would he agree with me not only will
that help to deter Chinese expansionism
in the Pacific but it is an absolutely
perfect example of global Britain
Thursday
Mr Speaker my right or my friend makes a
a very important point when I was
running through the list of things that
uh underpin our indo-pacific Focus uh I
didn't mention August because I know the
Prime Minister will be doing so
extensively later on today he asked
whether Isis whether I think that the
labor party will match that commitment
of 2.5 on defense spending and I say no
and I say no for two reasons firstly
because no uh opposition defense uh
Shadow Minister has made such commitment
and secondly because they won't be in
office in 2025 because we'll be in
government
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I think
we we Face our most panel with the
Polaris moment since the second world
war and the the height of the Cold War
uh and we've seen a very clear strategy
from Russia and China and of course Iran
to undermine democracy and Western
values
so what we've got today is a strategy
that actually does not actually give any
sort of signal or sign to Russia or
China Iran that we're being serious
about taking them home we are very we
need to do what it takes we need to do
what it takes for the government is to
decide that and this partner needs to
decide that we need to do what it takes
so what we've got today instead is this
poultry five billion that that is
foreign secretary has come here when
when when uh well Mr Speaker the the
Secretary State for the offense has made
it clear that once it's eight to eleven
billion that's right let me just give
you a direct quote Mr Speaker from the
select committee back in November uh
when he when he was asked about
inflation uh and he'd argue for an 11
billion increase over two years
sorry an 8 billion be increased over two
years they've got five billion it
doesn't even cover the inflationary part
of this it's an absolute nonsense the
government should be ashamed of
themselves they're letting down this
country yeah yeah
foreign
amongst that stream of Consciousness but
these simple truth of the matter is the
Secretary of State Defense was at this
dispatch box only a few minutes ago
welcoming this announcement he says 5
billion is a poultry sum I was just
reminded by my by my honorable friend
that is Lars in our prisons budget
um and and and his attitude towards
public money I think demonstrates the
classic problem with the party officer
when you when when the party suggests
that five billion pounds is an
insignificant sum it demonstrates a
blase attitude towards public
expenditure that sadly is the Hallmark
of the party opposite I keep that's it
Mr Speaker I thank my right Animal
Friend for this uh refresh I think it
makes the country stronger today many of
my constituents are concerned about the
rise of China does he agree with me that
China is one of the greatest challenges
we're going to face in the 21st century
and can he confirm that we must build on
our relationships in the indo-pacific
not just with our existing friends like
Australia India and Japan but we must
find new friends and new allies to
strengthen our hand
my honorable friend is is right that
it's important that we build on our
existing friendships and develop new
friendships in the uh indo-pacific
region and I would make the point that
those friendships those Partnerships are
a a good thing to do in of themselves
and not just in response to China's
activity but he's also right that of
course China has demonstrated a range of
behaviors which we oppose I've raised
those directly with representatives of
the Chinese government so it is right
that this review looks carefully at our
relationship with China those areas
where we need to defend ourselves and
our partners those areas where we need
to work more closely with them Dave
it's a fine glossy brochure but we've
waited an awful long time and there's
not an awful lot in it and the harsh
realities are at a time when inflation
is denuding the defense budget in the
way that it is when the euro-atlantic
posture of the United Kingdom needs to
redouble more than ever the United
Kingdom's committed itself to the
indo-pacific and we have a war in
Mainland Europe and the response is 5
billion it's not serious especially not
when two of that is to replenish stocks
which is non-discretionary so that's not
a policy position and the other three is
for nuclear why is there always money
for nuclear yeah
I'll tell you why I tell you why there's
always money for the foundation stone of
the Euro Atlantic defense posture is
because it's the foundation stone of the
Euro Atlantic defense posture and I have
to say when he starts talking about the
expenditure on the Armed Forces my thing
that my my heart goes out to those uh
brave men and women in our British Armed
Forces stationed in Scotland who pay
more tax than any other members of the
armed forces in the country
bro
Mr Speaker
um very much welcome um the review that
my wonderful friends announced today and
he uh he was talking about the um
critical mineral strategy enough
elements but I think if I could
highlight to my audible friends and ask
them to take this to other departments
to work alongside each other that
actually we all recognize the lessons to
be learned from Russia being reliant on
Russian minerals and how we've had to
change that but 95 of the elements that
are used in renewable energy solar
panels wherever are processed in China
now we can't escape the science of what
happens but we can ask other departments
to diversify how we're going to do
Renewables so could I ask my right and
well friend to take back to other
departments that we need to look at
investing in and working on things like
hydrogen combustion so that we're not
entirely reliant on minerals that are
going to come out of China
so State my right honorable friend is
absolutely right Russia's use of energy
supplies is a tool of coercion is
something that we have witnessed we must
ensure that we do two things firstly is
we wean ourselves off our Global
addiction to hydrocarbon energy for uh
for the reasons that we have seen but we
also need to make sure that in doing so
we do not inadvertently create a
dependency on any one other country
particularly China so uh our critical
mineral strategy will bear that in mind
and in the conversations I've had with
leaders in Africa for example who are
often the countries from which these
minerals are mined that are then shipped
to China to be processed it would be
better for them it would be better for
us a little better for the world if more
of that processing were done on the
continent of extraction rather than on
the other side of the world Holly Lynch
thank you very much Mr Speaker the
integrated review
refreshing recognizes the chat
from Iran
a country which is
which has been an assassination attempt
here in the UK since January of last
year the foreign office is widely
understood to be blocking attempts to
prescribe the argc can the foreign
secretary confirm if that is true and
can you explain given the seriousness of
the threat why we haven't yet prescribed
the iigc
Thursday we respond to the threats posed
by Iran both in the region against
people of their own country and
internationally and she is right to
highlight the numerous attempts that
have been made in the UK Mainland I pay
tribute to our security services and our
policing services for preventing a
number of attempted uh
attacks on the UK Mainland
um the decision about uh whether we
sanctioned prescribe is always one that
we discuss across government and any
decisions on future designations or
sanctions will be made across government
and I'm not and I'm not going to I'm not
going to speculate on what the future
actions may be taken by this government
Richard Drex
diplomacy must cover the Iron Fist does
my right or a friend agree with me that
to share my concern that even two and a
half percent on GDP on defense will
simply not be enough to give the foreign
office the support it needs to do its
job
so stay
uh the uh my honorable friend makes an
incredibly important part a point about
the close working relationship between
uh defense and diplomacy but also
International Development I can assure
him that the defense secretary and I and
the Prime Minister and the chancellor
are in close coordination to make sure
that the money that we spend defending
our nation and defending our interests
overseas is used most effectively that
will always underpin the decisions that
we uh that we make I recognize uh his
desire to see a greater money spent on
uh defense But ultimately we do need to
ensure that we protect the public purse
but we do so in a way that also protects
our interests and values religion Ford
thank you Mr Speaker the 2015 Strategic
Defense and Security review estimated
that the Dreadnought acquisition program
was likely to cost 31 billion pounds
including info
we've learned in the last week the
program remains within budget
but sdsr did set a contingency of 10
billion pounds how much of that 10
billion pounds contingency is being used
on Dreadnought and is the three billion
pairs that we've heard announced today
for nuclear separate from that 10
billion pounds
Mr Speaker the uh the future expenditure
as I say will be set out in more detail
by my right honorable friend the
chancellor of the exchequer and the ways
in which the defense secretary will
spend the money allocated to and will be
set out by defense ministers in the
future but I have to say uh that uh I
I'm still at the moment completely lost
as to what the lib Dems defense posture
is
um and certainly I look back at the time
that we were in government together and
I can't help but think that had we not
had the sea anchor of the lib Dems in
Coalition we would have progressed much
more quickly on securing the defense of
this country
Robert courts thank you Mr Speaker but
the extra money for uh stockpiles and
for August is indeed uh welcome
um but when the foreign actually rightly
speaks of a challenge to the entire
International order and we look for
example at two areas of capability just
in isolation the size of the Army and
the capability of the air Mobility Force
we have to face the unpalatable fact
that neither people nor equipment can do
two things at once will he be working
together with his own with his other
minister or colleagues to make sure that
the investment that we have matches and
provides the capability to set against
the challenges he rightly spoke of
so stay my honorable friend uh very
knowledgeable on this and the points he
makes are ones that we listen to
carefully I can only repeat that we will
continue as we have done uh over a
number of years now we will continue to
work very very closely to align our
foreign posture of Foreign Affairs
diplomacy posture and indeed our
International Development posture with
our defense posture to make sure that we
use most efficiently and effectively the
money that is given to us the public
funds the taxpayers money that is given
to us by the chancellor to ensure that
we protect British people and our
friends and our interests overseas
the the free reference day for the 5
billion over the next two years and a
commitment to spend 2.5 percent of UK
GDP on defense spending so let me ask
him very simply when will the commitment
to 2.5 of GDP come into effect and where
does this leave the British army will
there be further cuts
so you stay and I think the honorable
and Gallant gentleman for his question
the details of how the uh Secretary of
State Defense will spend his budget I
will have to leave to the Secretary of
State for defense the uh integrated
review refresh sets out the broad
parameters as I say uh uh bringing the
the five billion pounds bringing us up
to around two and a quarter percent of
GDP which is well on track to that 2.5
two and a half percent of GDP uh
commitment as I say the uh the nature of
that expenditure on what capabilities
and what equipment will be something
I'll leave to the defense secretary to
give more detail so Ian Duncan Smith
speaker can I uh welcome some of the
report that uh my writable friend has
brought to the house today but I want to
return to China as someone sanctioned I
take a particular interest in this I
have to say that I am somewhat confused
as to what the government's position
actually is it was as the Prime Minister
when Channel standing for election who
said China posed a systemic threat then
that was backed down to systemic
challenge to which we were going to meet
it with robust pragmatism that robust
pragmatism meant that we have sanctioned
nobody in Hong Kong when America is
sanctioned 10 though we have sanctioned
three low officials in xinjiang when
America sanctioned 11 including
chunquote the architect of that terrible
atrocity and we didn't kick out the
Chinese officials who beat people up on
the streets of the UK but now I
understand that's a move to epoch Epoch
defining challenge I just want to ask in
the document that the Prime Minister has
produced today in the same paragraph he
does refer to that Epoch defining
challenge but then he goes on to say
that this is in the face of that threat
so does that now mean that China is a
threat
or an Epoch defining challenge or a
challenging government Epoch or even
none of that
reassure my my right honorable friend
that in every meeting in every meeting
that I've had with representatives of
the Chinese government I've raised
specifically uh
their sanctioning of him and others in
this house as being completely
unacceptable behavior and I've
challenged I've challenged them on every
single occasion that I have had
conversations with the Chinese
government so I want to let him know on
that one I would make the point that
whilst I understand the desire to have a
a simple uh short phrase or indeed
single word to describe our posture
towards China with a com with the
country as uh as as as as big as
influential as significant as China it
is impossible to distill it down just to
a simple set of words or a phrase it's
not something we do with any other
country in the world we recognize that
international relations are more
complicated they'll be so there will be
that there is in the IR refresh and
there will be a uh uh more of a
narrative than just a single word
description because we want to describe
the areas where we can and should work
more closely with China the areas where
we need to defend ourselves and our
interests against China and the areas
where we want to steer China into a
different course of of action so we will
so there will always be descriptors
plural and I understand his uh I
understand his desire for a Clarity on
this and he will see through our actions
that we do respond robustly uh to China
when it behaves in a way that we
disagree with but we'll also attempt to
do China in a better Direction itself
way in which we have been working with
our European allies to resist Russia's
invasion of Ukraine is it not now time
to seek a form foreign policy and
security partnership with the European
Union alongside our leading role in NATO
Thursday uh well I've just come back at
the tail end of last week from the
Summits in Paris the uh UK France Summit
and our closer defense Corporation was
one of the main topics that we discussed
and indeed our broader Corporation with
member states of the European Union on
our Collective self-defense But
ultimately NATO has shown itself to be
the most effective mechanism for defense
of the Euro Atlantic region we have just
demonstrated the UK has demonstrated its
full commitment to Nato and through the
announcements that we've made today in
the previous announcements that we have
made we will continue to be one of the
leading contributory Nations to Nato and
that is the primary vehicle for our
Collective self-defense
Deputy speaker a Mr Speaker
um can I thank my writing friend for his
statement and for the presentation of
this paper which shows a far greater
strategic awareness of the vulnerability
that the whole of the West faces than we
would have seen in any document just a
few years ago but there isn't the Ghost
of the feast still the money I very much
welcome his commitment to 2.5 percent of
GDP for defense
but when are we going to see our Armed
Forces restored to the critical mass
that is capable of deterring the kind of
aggression we're seeing and recreating
the kind of aggressive policies we're
seeing from China because it seems that
the 5 billion he that is announced today
is going to patch up what we should have
been spending already it's not going to
make a huge difference
so to stay
my my right to a friend is right that uh
all defense postures need to be paid for
and that's why I'm very proud uh that we
had the uh 20 the um uh the additional 5
billion that we announced on top of the
money that was previous previously
announced in uh 2020. obviously when we
are talking about expenditure as a
percentage of GDP one of the best things
you can do is to grow the economy which
is why I'm fully supportive of the prime
minister's priority to grow the economy
so that we can have in absolute terms a
larger defense budget because it is a it
is a percentage of a growing economy I
would highlight the fact that that is in
stark contrast with a lack of commitment
that we've seen to a proportion to spent
spending uh from the opposition uh front
bench and no credible plan to grow the
economy either but I do take the point
that he makes uh to Heart okay well
thank you Mr Speaker that's the foreign
secretary agree no without a reversal to
his Department's devastating
International Aid cuts that the UK
government cannot claim to be fully
safeguarding vulnerable communities
around the world
Mr Speaker in in both absolute terms and
percentage terms the UK is still one of
the largest odor uh uh in absolute terms
and percentage terms the UK is still one
of the largest odor donating countries
in the world and uh I can assure her I
can assure her that in the conversations
that I have with Partners around the
world they hugely value the UK's
contribution they hugely value our
expertise and they hugely value the
corporation that we have with them
John Berlin
speaker
um
many aspects of the the statement are to
be welcome but including the essentially
one-off increases
um in both our hard and soft power
capabilities but does the foreign
secretary accept that one-off increases
are ad hoc
sporadic and make long-term planning
difficult and that what is required is a
fundamental threat-based review that is
backed by long-term funding because to
properly defend ourselves requires long
leading times across many aspects of our
defense
so stay Mr Speaker of course my
honorable friend is Right which is why
we have published the integrated review
refresh which is to set the framework
for the risks and opportunities in the
international sphere of course in
response to one-off events like Russia's
invasion of Ukraine we have to have
discrete responses but those are within
a wider framework of international
posture uh the uh the Prime Minister has
made it clear that this is this is part
of the journey towards our Baseline of
2.5 percent of GDP spent on defense
which is a commitment as I say which
which we absolutely will adhere to
Stephen Kennett thank you very much Mr
Speaker
um just building on the question by the
right tunnel gentleman the member for
chingford and wood green does the
foreign secretary agree with me that we
are in need of an in-depth strategic
audit of every aspect of our country's
relationship with China from defense to
diplomacy to technology to education to
cyber security and will he also assure
the house that there will be no return
to the utterly failed Golden Era
strategy
I can show my rights from a friend and
The Honorable gentleman that we are
absolutely looking at how China
interacts with the British State both in
the government level and in the other
areas whether it be in the commercial
world in the public sector in the
education sector and that is not to say
that we should never or must never have
Chinese investment in the UK I think
that would be unrealistic and
counterproductive but it must mean that
whatever relationship we have with China
we have to go into their eyes open we
have to properly assess what the
opportunities are but also what the
risks and threats are and that does need
to be done across government I can give
him uh and others in the house the
reassurance that's exactly how we will
approach our relationship with China
James Gray
girl very much multiple documents uh
strengths and robustness with God's
Russia's threat elsewhere apart from
Ukraine but I'm a little bit
disappointed there's a quick reading of
the document by how little it says about
the Arctic a half of uh Russia's Navy
and more than half actually is in the
Arctic 25 000 mile Coastline all of the
nuclear turns most of the uh economic
wealth comes from the Arctic yet there's
only one paragraph here devoted to it
and the threat quite frankly I think is
quite substantial I rather disappointed
By the Mark they often say which they
hope that the Arctic will return to the
region of both High cooperation low
tension and right am I right and
thinking Mr Speaker that's more of a
hope than the belief that actually
happened
Thursday uh well Mr Speaker I've had uh
conversations uh with my uh
Scandinavian Baltic and Canadian
counterparts on the risk to the Arctic
and the high North uh obviously in a
document which we are trying to make
modest in page number but wide in
aspiration we have got to be disciplined
in in how much space we put across but I
can assure him we are very conscious of
that risk The Joint expeditionary force
and the conversations I've had as I say
with my Nordic Baltic and Canadian
counterparts assessment to that hold the
Barker thank you Mr Speaker the extra
funding being made available to the BBC
World Services particularly welcome the
World Service does an admirable job of
supplying news in a world of
disinformation so can I ask the foreign
secretary why the government decided to
cut its funding in the first place
so stay
uh Mika when the impacts of covid were
felt across the world of course
governments in all countries of all
political Persuasions had to make
difficult decisions we of course did
likewise but I'm very very pleased that
we've been able to work with the BBC
World Service to ensure that they act or
they deliver their services in the most
efficient manner and that we're able to
support them with this increase in
funding
thank you sir given that the biggest
killer of our people uh the most
frequent
breaches of our border and indeed
arguably the most significant impact to
the Integrity of our economy is the work
of overseas organized criminal gangs why
is there hardly any mention of them in
this document and where is the resource
to allow the National Crime agency to
deal with threats that I've felt on the
streets of the Secretary of State's
constituency in mine every single day
Thursday uh Mr Speaker he's absolutely
right but um organized criminal gangs do
have an international uh component and
this document is predominantly uh
predominantly but not exclusively
focused on uh State Level Threats but I
can assure him that in our interactions
with our uh interlocutors
internationally the role of organized uh
crime gangs International organized
current gangs is very much part of the
conversations that we have again uh when
we we didn't have the uh we didn't have
the opportunity to put every single
element of what we do internationally
and of course
um a large part of that is within the
home Affairs uh era of responsibility
but we liaise very very closely to
ensure that when I am speaking with
International interlocutors that the
threat within the UK posed by
International criminality is one of the
things that we discuss Andrew Gwen thank
you I refer to my registered entries I
was really pleased that the foreign
secretary referred to today being
Commonwealth day a little disappointed
that there was only a passing reference
to the Commonwealth uh in that he's
meeting foreign ministers from uh those
member states uh in the coming week he
was right to highlight the growing
influence of China across the globe and
that includes economic political and
security interests amongst many of the
56 members of the Commonwealth so how
does he envisage the integrated review
refresh in terms of Britain developing a
modern dynamic refreshed friendship with
many of those countries in the
Commonwealth
so to stay I I genuinely Thank The
Honorable gentleman for raising uh this
issue and whilst we've not made uh many
references to the Commonwealth
discreetly within this it is actually
interwoven through much of what we do
our indo-pacific tilt because of the
geographical nature of the Commonwealth
inevitably means that that will be
delivered in partnership with uh
commonwealth countries orcas of course
with Australia but this morning I spoke
to the uh single Korean foreign minister
the New Zealand foreign minister had
meetings with a Malaysian foreign
minister so I can assure him that the UK
wants to see the Commonwealth as being a
meaningful active and useful vehicle for
the member states particularly those
small island States who
disproportionately
create the membership of the
Commonwealth so I can assure him I can
reassure him in fact that even if it's
not written down explicitly it's
absolutely interwoven throughout this
document John witting there thank you Mr
Speaker I want my right friend agree
that soft path can often be as effective
as hard power if not more so and it is
usually a lot cheaper can I therefore
strongly welcome the additional funding
for the BBC World Service but will he go
on and look at strengthening support for
other soft power projections such as the
British Council and the chiefening
scholarship and John Smith Fellowship
programs yeah
friend my near neighbor in Essex I
suspect knows that he is pushing at the
openest of open doors with regards to
that I I I don't particularly like the
phrase soft power because I think it
sometimes implies a subordinate
relationship to hard power and he is
absolutely right that the UK's I'm gonna
have to use it because I haven't thought
of anything else better yet but the UK's
projection of soft power is so
incredibly powerful it is incredibly
cost effective and the and the uh and
and the
um and the points that you made about
achieving Scholars Marshall Scholars and
other football Arts Theater all these
things are incredibly powerful and
absolutely at the heart of UK uh foreign
policy
thank you Mr Speaker William Gladstone's
third Midlothian speech said that good
foreign policy started with good
government at home now we can see that
in the U.S with President Biden's
inflation reduction act we see it with
the chips act we can see it even in the
European Union being jolted into
responding with similar initiatives but
the somewhat vague promises in the
document published today Mr Speaker of a
protective security Authority and
economic deterrence initiative a
critical
little strategy UK semiconductor
strategy leave me somewhat wanting more
can the foreign secretary expand on
these things because if he doesn't if
there's no meat on the bone then we will
fail to have met the moment that the
White House and the Commission in
Brussels has set us
I mean there was the phrase always
always leaving wanting more is that not
what they uh is that not what they say
in uh was it politics is
politics Show Business rugby people
um but
um I can assure him I can assure him
that it will remain as I said in my
statement to the house it will remain
absolutely the heart of UK's foreign
policy to work in Partnership and with
Partners we need to make sure that we
maintain our tradition as being an open
free trading Nation working closely with
those countries that share our values
and protect our interests as we do with
theirs he highlighted a number of
further iterations uh that uh I I
highlighted in this including our
services conductors including our
critical mineral strategy more details
more details will be coming and he will
see that those things are into over not
just through the UK foreign policy
structure but also in close cooperation
with our friends and allies
internationally Anna Bruce
speaker a commitment to promoting
freedom of religion or belief or form
was included in the last integrated
review and it's good to hear from the
foreign secretary today that the
approach on working on this refresh has
been one of evolution so does he agree
that the UK continuing to take a leading
role in promoting and protecting freedom
of religion or belief across the world
and working with like-minded countries
to challenge its abuses is as important
indeed even more important today than it
was in the 2021 review bearing in mind
the increased abuses which are happening
across the world not least for example
Russia's misuse of religion in its
attacks against Ukraine and also being
in the growing use of increasingly
sophisticated technology to control
coerce and oppress people and restrict
their freedom of religion or belief
I pay tribute to my honorable friends
work in this area and she is right that
freedom of religion or belief is one of
those litmus paper tests for uh
good behaviors by government where where
those freedoms are impinged it is
typically the canary in the mine for
other human rights abuses uh she's right
that uh we highlighted it in 2001 we
have absolutely not lost our commitment
to it this is a refresh didn't we did
not attempt to cover off everything that
we covered in the 21 uh integrated
review because otherwise the document
itself would have been too large
great
because really confirmed that it's no
longer government policy to view the Eid
budget as a giant cash machine in the
sky and will you recognize that where
Cuts have been made they are having a
tangible and negative impact why won't
he show the same level of ambition to
return to 0.7 gni for Aid spending as a
showing to get to 2.5 gni for defense
spending Thursday and the gentleman
should listen when we make statements to
the dispatch talks because we have made
the commitment to get back up to uh 0.7
uh and the uh as the same response to
the honorable ladies question we remain
both in percentage terms and absolute
terms one of the largest state donors in
the world
[Music]
welcome the review Refresh on China
capabilities as I think the only
Mandarin and Cantonese speaker in the
house can I encourage the foreign
secretary to increase the number of
Great Britain China Center courses for
both civil servants and parliamentarians
on the integrated reviews assessment of
Middle Ground powers of growing
importance which include the three
Southeast Asian Nations and asean to
which I serve as he knows
um does he agree with me that Although
our national interests will not always
be the same we do all share a strong
interest in an open International order
and therefore that we should as my right
honorable friends suggested sharply
increase fcdo achieving scholarships
British Council scholarship Armed Forces
courses scholarships and Westminster
foundation for democracy programs in the
indo-pacific region to make those closer
Partnerships the review calls for
I think it is incumbent upon us to make
sure that we understand China better I'm
not fatalistic about our future
relationship with China the uh the job
of Foreign Affairs the job of diplomacy
is try to influence to improve and we
certainly seek to influence China's uh
decisions and say we uh it is clear that
we do need to uh increase the number of
people who speak Chinese and therefore
intimately understand uh China that's
why we have made the commitment to do so
with regards to the other schemes that
he highlighted he's absolutely right
that the more people that understand us
well the better
referee
because some analysts believe that a war
over Taiwan sovereignty could occur in
the second half of this decade although
the Prime Minister has voiced his wish
to continue to engage with China over
the past 24 hours this reform secretary
agree that conflict in the region would
have devastating impacts and that we
must protect taiwan's rights as an
independent nation
The Honorable lady is absolutely right
that a conflicts across the Taiwan
Straits would be disastrous not just for
the region but for the global economy
because of the interplay into
interconnected Supply chains that would
be at stake at the UK's position uh uh
is long-standing and well-versed we
don't agree with any unilateral change
of posture across the Taiwan Straits and
we will continue to work to maintain
peace to de-escalate where there are
intentions and to try and ensure that we
have peace in that region the plastic
thank you Mr Speaker that's a wonderful
friendly career that the government's
commitment to increase defense spending
is 2.5 percent of GDP will not only to
help keep us safe but also create much
more certainty for the 390
000 UK jobs many of which are high
paying high skilled in places like
filtering and Bradley Stoke which rely
on our defenseman
Thursday we we have fantastic defense
Industries uh here in the UK I think
that the uh the reason that uh countries
are Keen to work with us on projects
like orcas and fcast and on others is
because internationally they recognize
the huge value that is added to defense
systems by engagement of
um the UK whether it be at governmental
level or in the commercial sector we
absolutely value the jobs based in the
UK's defense sector and it of course is
about preserving those jobs
including of course because those jobs
are more geographically dispersed than
in other sectors of the UK economy good
value high paid jobs High skills jobs
across the whole of the UK is actually
what we will continue to focus on Jim
shutter thank you Mr Speaker can I thank
the minister very much for for his
statement and also the government
annotation regarding the increase in
defense spending as this is something
that I along with many others in this
house have been asking for years I note
that this is in response to Russia and
the global concerns I also note that the
minister when he made a step in today
referred to the increase in cyber and
Technology
there's also an importance Mr uh speaker
to have an increase of soldiers and
those in the ground in other words puts
in the ground is it not possible to have
both both cyber and Technology but also
boots in the ground could the minister
give that on to that point cycling
uh The Honorable and gentleman I think
makes an incredibly important point that
just because new threats have emerged as
we have seen with Russia's invasion of
Ukraine the old threats do not go away
and we are seeing a full spectrum attack
by Russia including Cyber attack missile
attack tank attack and sadly first world
war style trench warfare around bakmut
so we have to understand it is not a
case of either or it has to be both this
uh integrated review refresh recognizes
that and I can assure him in the house
that we will make sure that we cover all
the areas where we need to defend
ourselves cheers Morris speaker as he's
already said uh Britain's soft power is
a strategic asset so what the foreign
secretary agree with me that it it's
important for two reasons one that it
gives us a strategic advantage in the
world but two it enables us to have a
platform to build relationship with
allies to contain and resist the trend
towards anti-democratic and
authoritarian regimes around the world
and my honorable friend is absolutely
right the UK proudly uh is is one of the
most significant uh defense contributors
to Nato as I said it is in absolute
terms and percentage terms one of the
largest age Spenders in the world but
but the one area where we are I think
without risk of of of being contradicted
is in our soft is in our soft power we
will continue to recognize that we will
continue to invest in that and we'll
continue to make sure that is the
hospital foreign policy
thank you Mr Speaker the five billion
pound investment in defense spending in
the upcoming orcas announcements offer
substantial opportunities for those
engaged in a nuclear Enterprise and the
submarine building program but they also
make clear the challenges we're going to
have to skill up the people for this
multi-generation long program and get
our supply chains ready to deliver on it
can my writable friend outline what
cross-government discussions are taking
place now to make sure we're fit for
that challenge
my honorable friend is uh is absolutely
right this is a not just across
government but across Society
multi-decade Long Endeavor which means
that we will need people who are
currently still perhaps in Primary
School
developing those technical skills that
will still be needed in 20 30 years time
and for those careers advisors around
the country I would suggest that
advising uh boys and girls to gravitate
towards this area of work is a very good
investment because the jobs are going to
be there and they're going to be high
paid high school jobs scattered all
around the UK they're going to be there
for a very very long time and he is
absolutely right there's needs to be a
whole society approach that's exactly
the attitude that we're taking usually
if you work through the church
right because
let people leave before we start the
next step into the witch through
which we come to the next statement
Minister Griffis
but yeah
miss Mr Speaker with your permission
I'll make a statement on the steps his
Majesty's government have taken to limit
risk